foreign
there are many downsides to living in a
collapsing civilization overall I find
the experience frankly unpleasant it's
not something I would recommend but
there are a few small benefits one one
is that it's never difficult to find
fodder for this segment of the show it
can be a bit of a stretch sometimes
honestly filling out an entire hour but
I never have trouble finding material
for the daily cancellation content for
this segment Sprouts out of the ground
it falls out of the sky grows on trees
we are surrounded by it all the time
this is a this is a very meager Silver
Lining I admit but we have to take what
we can get and in our culture there is
always someone next in line presenting
my next daily cancellation segment to me
doing my work for me today it's the Wall
Street Journal with an article about
what it calls the hot new invite divorce
parties the article begins quote after
Brandy stellars finalized her divorce
she invited close friends to a soiree in
May she uh she mixed signature cocktails
hung a bye Felicia banner and handed out
fake rose petals to toss in the air
party decorations included a photo of a
pair of penguins torn down the middle I
ripped the Penguins in half because
penguins are monogamous Birds who are
supposed to mate for life she says well
I'm not your penguin anymore
the newly uncoupled are throwing
themselves blowout bashes to mark their
Liberation from unhappy marriages almost
like reverse bachelorette parties I
wanted to celebrate not a divorce but a
new chapter with people whom I love who
want the best for me so sellers who
works at a cloud computing company in
Columbus Ohio
divorce used to be something to be
ashamed of due to societal pressures and
stereotypes as Nicole sedoma a divorce
lawyer who wrote the book please don't
say you're sorry about the topic but
today people have really decided to nip
that societal shame and instead Embrace
being divorced as another stage of life
that some of us experience
by the way I like the the bit about
penguins because what she's basically
saying is that we I am not able to live
up to the standard of a penguin okay
penguin that that is a moral standard
that I cannot meet penguins
now how about a you know a spider that
mates
with the the male spider and then
devours it
that's that's more that's more where she
is I think
but yeah divorce is just another stage
of Life uh says the divorce lawyer kind
of like um you know totaling your car at
the bottom of a ravine it's just another
stage of driving home from work burning
down your house is just another stage of
building it choking to death on a
chicken bone it's just another stage of
eating dinner
that's what we're hearing from the
divorce lawyer who of course has
absolutely no Financial motive to
promote and normalize divorce this is
certainly an unbiased Observer whose
insights we can trust
definitely
reading on quote on Etsy and Amazon
Brands sell split Splitsville swag
including end of an error sashes thank
you next uh rose gold foil balloons and
I do I did I'm done t-shirts on
Pinterest the online platform for
sharing creative ideas search Trends
show that people are gaining A New
Perspective on divorce says swasty sarna
Global director of Data Insights at
Pinterest Pinterest searches for divorce
party games surged 80 percent and
searches for divorce cakes Rose 50 in
June 2022 from a year earlier there were
also jumps and searches for diverse
divorce party decorating ideas 35 and
for divorce gifts 30 according to
Pinterest it was just this feeling of
I'm not ashamed of this says Nadine
Adamson a real estate broker in
Manhattan and Brooklyn who had a divorce
party I think being married for more
than 10 years in New York I was married
for 12 is a huge success
well we can't even talk about lowering
the bar anymore because at this point
it's buried under the ground you barely
have to lift your feet to get over it
you can crawl and get over the bar at
this point it's never been more clear
that the left is giving up their morals
and any common sense that they maybe
once had there is no better time to
build a daily habit of prayer and
meditation building a habit of prayer
can help you cultivate an attitude of
gratitude focusing on what you are
thankful for can increase positive
emotions and improve overall well-being
hallow is the number one Christian
Prayer app in the U.S it's helped me
maintain daily prayer routines and can
help you do the same download the app
for free at hello.com Matt Walsh you can
set prayer reminders and track your
progress along the way not sure where to
start we'll check out father Mike
schmitz's Bible in the year podcast
available in the Hello app for brief
daily readings and Reflections you can
pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel even some world-class athletes
with how low you can customize a
personal prayer plan that works for you
listen wherever you are with
downloadable offline sessions using
hello to connect with others who share
your beliefs and values can provide a
sense of belonging to give you support
and Foster a sense of community as well
ultimately we'll learn how we can become
better individuals in spite of today's
broken worlds we strive to become more
like Christ in our daily lives through
prayer fasting and giving download Hello
hello.com Matt Walsh and get three
exclusive months free that's three
months absolutely free at hello.com Matt
Walsh being married for 12 years and
then divorcing is a success she says a
huge success
this is like saying that a man is a is a
hugely successful swimmer if he makes it
a quarter of the way across the pool and
then drowns and dies
I can imagine Nadine watching the guy
sink below the surface because of course
she wouldn't try to help him and
declaring wow he's just like Michael
Phelps what a great swimmer
continuing quote Adamson had friends
from Los Angeles fly to New York and
they booked the hotel suite where she
had stayed when she got married it felt
like closure in a really beautiful way
to be in the same hotel with the same
view she says the four of them burned
sage in the sweet to rid of a ridded of
negative Vibes filled the place with
balloons dined out and then had a
sleepover
Adamson also continues to a post on
Instagram with the hashtag divorceparty
not because she keeps throwing them but
as a way to highlight her new life such
as upgrading her Brownstone with a cozy
wood burning fireplace
I guess divorce parties are a thing a
Reddit user wrote a few months ago in a
post that Drew nearly 4 000 comments the
poster included a photo of an invitation
from a divorcing couple that was
throwing a joint party plus ones are
welcome ours will be there it said
now you get the idea but eventually the
article ends with this anecdote quote
travel blogger Maja prosculpt says that
her divorce process done without lawyers
was lengthy enough that by the time the
paperwork was done much of her grief had
settled and she was ready for a party
her sister supplied a crown and a finely
divorced sash the group went out dancing
where the club's DJ called out let's
have it for maja's divorce party
that was a top that was a top life
moment for me she says
a top life moment well then Maja um you
have lived an incredibly pathetic life
and that is the case for all of these
divorce parties nearly all of whom you
may have noticed are women
the fact that the divorce party
phenomenon is almost entirely driven by
women is yet more evidence that the
divorce epidemic itself is mostly driven
by women women are more likely to
initiate divorce much more likely to
throw themselves a party celebrating the
Betrayal of their vows and this is not
the point that we're going to focus on
today but it is worth noting now there's
a lot of discussion including this week
about what's wrong with men in our
culture but this is more evidence that
women have some very serious problems of
Their Own to put it mildly
now putting that aside the article notes
that there used to be a lots of Shame
and stigma surrounding divorce and these
parties are meant to be in part A
corrective to that a way of
destigmatizing what had been stigmatized
you'll notice that our society is
obsessed with destigmatizing
but the problem is that we we take away
the stigma without asking why the stigma
was there in the first place
divorce was treated as an embarrassing
and shameful thing in the past
because it is embarrassing and shameful
you are breaking a promise
it is deranged to actively celebrate the
breaking of a promise no matter what the
promise was
you know we've all broken promises in
our lives this is a human foible
but it's quite another thing to applaud
the breaking of a promise to celebrate
its as a somehow enriching and
life-affirming choice
and this is not just any promise
this is a solemn vow made to someone you
claim to love a vow that you built a
whole life around
and now you're tearing that life into
pieces and leaving lots of collateral
damage including oftentimes your
children
and it's wake
it's not just inappropriate to celebrate
this it is psychotic
yes the divorce may start a new chapter
in your life uh you know just like if
you get into a drunk driving accident
and wind up in jail for manslaughter
that'll also start a new chapter in your
life
but just because it's new doesn't mean
it's good
and this is not exactly a profound
Insight but it comes as news to many in
our culture not all new things are good
okay
in fact I'm not even sure that new
chapter is the right way of looking at
this
because when you abandon your marriage
and your family it's less that you're
adding a new chapter to your book and
it's more that you're giving up on the
book
you know you began writing the story
when you met your spouse
and you wrote a a story together it's a
saga full of joy and hardship and love
and sacrifice divorce is not the next
chapter in that book but it's the abrupt
and unceremonious and unsatisfying and
anticlimactic end to the great novel
that you had been composing together
now you start a whole new book
but the thing is that you're going to so
often find that the new one is at best a
pale imitation of the one you gave up on
the one you ruined by ending too early
divorce is not anything to celebrate
it's something to Lament
so if you have a ceremony to commemorate
your divorce it should be less like a
bachelorette party and more like a wake
with an open casket displaying your
broken promise and your broken family
a somber occasion of mourning
that would at least be honest
still kind of weird though
and that is why divorce parties are
today canceled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there